wildfires are destroying huge swaths of
territory around europe
finland has been battling its biggest
forest fire in half a century
heat waves are also causing havoc
further south
the worst blazes are raging in southern
turkey where six people have been killed
greece has also been hit hard
the smoke in greece is becoming a hazard
so much so that hospitals are now
admitting patients with
breathing difficulties greek authorities
had warned that wildfires could erupt in
temperatures reaching 45 degrees celsius
since we don't seem to understand that
we have to protect the environment
unfortunately this is how the weather is
going to be
in greece and elsewhere scientists are
linking the heat wave
and the wildfires to climate change
in italy firefighters have been working
day and night
to douse the flames
on the island of sicily the fires in the
mountains are also threatening
seaside resorts 150 tourists were moved
out
in turkey hundreds more holidaymakers
were ferried to safety
after the forest fires got too close to
their hotels coast guards asked
boat owners to help with the rescue
operation
inland farmers are helpless as their
animals perish
dozens of villages have been evacuated
president erdogan has been quick to
point the finger at his political
opponents
we know that the fire in marmaris was
caused by children but an investigation
into the other fires
is still ongoing
we do not rule out the possibility that
someone was told to start them
it is our duty to find those who burn
our forests
and tear their hearts out
turkish authorities say they have
brought most of the fires
under control but the hot weather
is expected to continue for the next few
days
go straight to dw correspondent yulia
hahn who is joining us from the
monavigat district in the turkish
province of antalya
one of the worst hit areas by the
wildfires julia what's the latest on the
ground
i'm in one of the villages near the town
of manafort where the fire
was raging just a few days ago and you
can see
the destruction left by the flames now
many buildings many homes like this one
there
right behind me have completely
burned out i can still smell the smoke
in the air almost the entire village has
been turned
into ashes now many people here
were brought elsewhere or went elsewhere
to stay there overnight so right now the
village is pretty much
deserted they told me they were able to
save their own lives
but they lost their livelihoods because
many people here in the area are farmers
they lost their fields their crops their
animals it's all gone
and now let's look a little further to
this direction this is the local mosque
it's also been
damaged by the fire now it's being used
to
organize aid people are collecting water
bread and clothing so the most necessary
items
to help people out now according to the
authorities more than a hundred
separate fires erupted in recent days
here in southern turkey and in western
turkey at the aegean coast
the vast majority of them they say are
now under control but a few are still
raging
so the firefighting operations continue
here in antarctica province as well
a wild wide-reaching wildfire with the
devastating effects uh president erdogan
has
visited the affected region facing a lot
of criticism
what more can you tell us about that
well yes he was here yesterday to
inspect the damages he
again promised quick help he said the
government would cover the rents of
people
affected and would rebuild their homes
as soon as possible
he also rejected criticism that had
emerged particularly on social media
concerning his government's
crisis management people were saying
that the authorities did not react
fast enough that they did not have the
proper equipment to get the situation
under control now erdogan said
that the number of firefighting planes
for example
had been increased recently from 6 to
13.
he said turkey got help there from
russia
ukraine azerbaijan and iran
now as we speak the cause of the fires
here in entire province
remains unclear the authorities suspect
that at least some of the blazes were
caused by arson because the fires broke
out
in separate different locations at the
same time
so an investigation into this is still
ongoing
really was it so difficult to get these
fires under control
well first let me mention that wildfires
in this region are common
especially in summer but it is very hot
right now
41 degrees celsius as we speak it's very
dry
the soil is very dry and there
have been strong winds they have been
fanning the flames
and all of that has made it very very
difficult for firefighting operations
for firefighters
to get the situation under control
that's a dw correspondent yulia hahn in
antalya turkey thanks so much
and joining me now from oslo is ketan
joshi
a climate analyst uh welcome to the
program mr
joshie now for days we've seen dozens of
wildfires ravaging in turkey and italy
and greece
and in turkey they're saying the
investigation to the start of the fire
is still going on but looking at
the the scale of these fires the
ferocity would you say this is no
coincidence
certainly not this is precisely what has
been warned
for uh quite some time around the
impacts of burning
fossil fuels and consequently the
climate change that we see
across the world uh many of the themes
that were touched on in that report just
then
uh strike me as very almost precisely
the same as the wildfires of
2019 2020 in australia
and of course the way that the wildfires
have emerged in the u.s
north america as well so certainly not a
coincidence and
something that we know for sure is being
made more intense
as the consequence of burning fossil
fuels and northern europe
including germany was recently hit by
other
extreme weather extreme forces of nature
looking at the flooding we just saw
this is making people question if the
climate has
become more chaotic what are your
thoughts
certainly what we're seeing is a rise in
extremes this is something that doesn't
always manifest in the way
that you might intuit it does uh from a
warming planet so
uh for instance more water and more
moisture is stored in the
atmosphere when temperatures rise which
leads to greater rainfall and uh more
intense flooding events
this manifests differently all across
the world and of course it manifests
differently according to
local factors as well but unfortunately
what we are seeing
is that the consequences of adding
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
are resulting in a more chaotic as you
say atmosphere
uh and it's something again that was
predicted in general but unfortunately
these extremes
are perhaps somewhat worse than than was
predicted
the goal set out in the paris climate
accord is to cap
global warming at 1.5 degrees how
important
is it for this goal to be achieved
sooner rather than later and
is this really likely
when it comes to the emissions
reductions that need to be achieved
to reach a certain temperature goal what
is really
really important is that the bulk of
emissions reductions actually need to
occur
sooner rather than later and that is
because
uh the total quantity of greenhouse
gases that you add to the atmosphere
results in worse warming which basically
means the later we leave it
the worse the consequences even if we do
achieve say a net zero by 2050 target
across the world
uh if we do it sooner then the
consequences will be less bad
those disasters that you mentioned will
hypothetically be less severe or which
is of course something that we want
as to the feasibility of it i think it
is certainly
very very feasible it's something that
can be done uh there's something
what we see across the world is that
countries that really
put their mind to it and put effort into
it and achieving far more than was
anticipated
as to whether it's likely it depends on
how hard we try and how hard
companies and governments push towards
that goal okay
joshie climate analyst speaking to us
from oslo thank you
thank you
you